les disques vinyles sont de retour en
force
selon les dernières indications les
ventes de vinyles vont se passer celle
de disques compacts aux états unis pour
l'année qui vient de se terminer
du jamais vu depuis 1986 on observe la
même tendance au canada quoique moins
prononcé près deux millions de vinyles
ont été vendus en 2019 une hausse de 3%
pendant ce temps 5 millions de disques
compacts ont été rendus une chute de 25%
les ventes d'albums numériques sont
aussi en baisse celle écoute en continu
sur des plateformes comme spotify qui a
le vent dans les voiles
aux etats unis la diffusion en continu
représente 80 % des revenus générés dans
l'industrie de la musique
[Musique]